you have a reputation whether this is
deserved or not as more interventionist
when it comes to foreign policy and here
you are talking about cutting forward
I'm the wife of a military wife do you
think I want my husband to go to war
it's the total opposite what I want is
our military to be so strong nobody
wants to touch it and that's where we
have to go everything we do should
always be about preventing War we should
never but you don't prevent War by
cowering you don't prevent War by
looking weak you don't prevent War by
being scared of the enemy you prevent
more by being strong and letting them
know what you expect and you tell them
not to doubt you that's what we did at
the United Nations I told countries what
America was for and what America was
against I didn't care if they didn't
like me but I wanted them to respect
America that's what we have to do